Should you preemptively kill a zombie? Of
course! I believe it was either Pliny
the Elder or Ving Rhames who said,  "It is
good to kill zombies". But on this matter,
I suspect the founders would consult
John Locke. Stipulated, there are many
kinds of zombies: fast, slow, undead, rage
virus, Chicago voters. But in every case,
the societal collapse of a zombie
apocalypse qualifies as what John Locke
called a "state of war", a state of
permanent conflict of all against all
like in "The Walking Dead" or a Black
Friday sale at Target.
All the zombies want to eat your face or
brains. For Locke, this is "a settled
design upon another man's life." Locke
continues "one may destroy a man who
makes war upon him... for the same reason
he may kill a wolf or lion... because such
men are not under the ties of the commonlaw
of reason, and... will be sure to
destroy him whenever he falls into their
power." Well, if humans need killing in that
context, surely there's no need to debate
the undead.
How will you prepare for the zombie apocalypse?
Let us know in your
comments! Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.